[Music]
obviously you get recognized all over
the place all over the world now as phil
dunphy but before that role
i mean
what was your career like what kind of
roles were you well i played sort of a
string of terrible terrible people like
a string of jerks i was the guy in many
many movies where when i would come out
the people in the audience were
basically like i can't wait to see him
get killed or fired right some at some
point
over the top jerk exactly who's gonna
get his comeuppance
and uh
my mom
finally started to freak out about it a
little bit like people are start you
know thinking that maybe you're
you're a jerk
and you know could you maybe take some
parts that aren't quite so you know mean
or terrible and so the last movie that i
did where i was playing just a horrible
horrible human being
i
i actually had to skirt around i tried
to describe she was like so tell me
about the movie tell me about the part
and i was like well
he's he's a very hard worker
he's he loves he loves people mainly
mainly women but but people
and then at the end of the movie he's
urged to find a another job where his
drive
you know his drive will be met with she
was like you're playing another [ __ ]
aren't you
then you you played you did a zombie
movie didn't you do a zombie movie i did
you and dawn of the dead yeah
i think we have a still from dawn of the
dead
[Applause]
yeah i was that way through the whole
movie but just doing regular dialogue
yeah like oh
my therapist
um
yeah i don't get recognized ever from i
mean everyone knows you from modern film
but does anyone ever say wait a minute i
know you're from dawn of the dead yeah
actually right when we were i mean it
happens occasionally but um
the best one was a woman who was
actually working security for modern
family out in front of uh our trailers
out in front of my trailer by my door
and i was walking back to my trailer
after lunch and she said hey i recognize
you from dawn of the dead and i said oh
cool
she said i love that movie and i was
like yeah me too i think you know i
thought it was really good and she said
i loved i loved you in that movie and i
said well thank you so much and she said
i i loved you in that scene and i was
like well i what scene what i don't know
what scene and she goes
i'm not kidding
what was the scene it was a
it was a fornicating scene when you were
working out yeah yeah
when i was uh doing that rotating
swinging something wait a minute zombies
don't have sex no i wasn't i wasn't dead
yet
clearly
so i just kind of scurried off and never
i didn't go into my trailer
the weirdest one i ever had is i had
someone stop me go wait i know you
you're that guy from conan
yeah
um
fans ever confuse you with the dunphy
because you play phil dunphy so well do
they ever think you're that guy well uh
they do i mean people normally will just
say like hey love the show or something
and you know thanks so much but if
you're
the drunker they are the more they treat
you like your
character basically or they actually
kind of like act like you're their
character and i actually had this happen
where i was in a
bar uh
and a guy came up and was like
dude
phil
phil
that clear that claire is a keeper
she's tough on you but that's good you
know that's good we need that we all
need that
luke is an idiot like you
[Laughter]
it's nice that's nice so much he just
needs a few more drinks i find sometimes
people who've had a lot to drink because
you're on tv they kind of think that you
work for them have you ever had that
they kind
[Applause]
or you like walk out of a building and
they treat you like you're basically one
of the disney characters at disney you
know where they're like hey he's like
like handing a camera to you like hey
take a picture of me and phil and you're
just standing there
with you with the phil head on
which is so hot it gets so hot in there
it is the thing that awaits all of us
i'm gonna beat the styrofoam conan
someday at seven flags
don't take off the head